[Musique]
bonsoir à tous max québec
walt disney phil knight et tant d'autres
pourquoi les nations dans lesquelles les
jeunes sont les principaux acteurs de
changement social qui imposerait
tendance à l'économie mondiale pourquoi
derrière chacune des grandes
multinationales de leur époque et bien
jaune qui a saisi l'opportunité qui
s'est présentée au lieu d'attendre que
les conditions soient favorables pour se
lancer
il y aurait il un lien de cause à effet
je suis ghana tabu ley ces entrepreneurs
béninois
j'ai 15 ans et mon expérience m'a
persuadé que oui il a des liens de cause
à effet vous vous demandez sûrement
comment c'est possible
église et entrepreneurs surtout dans un
environnement comme le nôtre où la seule
chose qu'un enfant est supposé faire à
mon âge c'est mémoriser cette cour et
c'est d'être classe je suis donc là ce
sera pour vous dire pourquoi je pense
que ce genre de présupposés doivent être
relégués dans les abysses des
conventions bottes il ya environ deux
ans je venais d'obtenir mon brevet
d'étude du premier cycle et je figurais
parmi les meilleurs lauréats sur le plan
national
c'était un garçon comme tout autre avec
un rêve je voulais m'investir dans la
robotique
mais les moyens pécuniaires de mes
parents est à limiter la perspective
d'un terrain de préciser d'école de
robotique risquait de ne jamais rester
pour moi qu'un doux rêve
il me fallait agir c'est alors ils ont
participé au google espère un concours
mondial de science pour les 13 à 18 ans
où les jeunes de par le monde venait
présenter leurs inventions et
découvertes dans divers domaines de la
science et de la technologie
c'était une occasion en or pour moi pour
réaliser mon rêve est pas le même
truchement on apprend plus sur la
robotique mais passionné temps et donc
décidé de m'y inscrire avec un ami
les jeunes comme moi les rêveurs cela
coeur de grandes ambitions en afrique ce
n'est ce qu'il voit
mais c'est plus à chaque fois et les
mains problème le manque de moyens
pécuniaires un marché défavorable une
médaille non compétentes
la formation dans les écoles
prestigieuses qui a sonné heureuse pour
ça je le savais je vous vois dans des
cités d'atteindre la tente que le temps
passe nathan que le bas qui sont
favorables d'attendre que les uns se
rendre compte des enjeux de vos projets
à l'heure les gratifie ciel est au
centre des pourparlers dans les
bibliothèques mais il ya des choses que
nous allons parfois oubliés d'abord un
rêve mais de l'avis de faire de notre
fille a mis en valeur qu'il soit un rêve
n'est de la prise de conscience du fait
qu'il lui manque quelque chose pour être
véritablement epagny devenu millionnaire
c'est un moins bon prix mais que parce
que sa situation financière ne satisfait
pas
on prévoit de près de 15 kilos en trop
c'est parce que nous sommes conscients
du fait que le kilo en trop sont un réel
problème pour notre santé quand nous
avons vingt ans que nous sommes comme un
grand malade en quête de quelque chose
qui pourrait le soulager nous satisfaire
remettre dans ses ambitions à plus tard
c'est être un peu comme ce malade qui
refusent de se soigner parce que existe
vraiment un argument plausible ou
excuser un reflet de soi et à l'instant
de mal latent réaliser ses rêves c'est
la chose la plus sérieuse qui soit une
urgence pour notre propre bien-être le
jour j'ai décidé de me lancer dans un
projet d' inventions
malgré que les conditions semblaient
défavorable et pris la décision la plus
importante de ma vie
alors peut être qu'aujourd'hui vous vous
dites que vous n'avez pas le capital
décidé de passer à l'action
quelle petite question pour vous que
faites vous donc concrètement pour
disposer de ce capital à chacune des
actions composant qui compte pour la
réserve aux objectifs et bretons
aujourd'hui vous croyez trop jeunes ou
trop vieux
pensez vous que dans dix ans vous serez
tout aussi déterminés à agir
pouvez vous garantir que le temps
n'aurait pas effritée votre
détermination commencé tôt peut être
pour notre région
un véritable atout une chose que le solo
parfois oublié c'est que l'afrique notre
continent est aujourd'hui et cela grâce
au numérique eldorado de l'innovation
ce n'est pas moi qui le dit ce soit un
chiffre une étude de mckinsey datant de
2013 révèle l'extraordinaire potentiel
du numérique en afrique d'ici 2025
internet contribuera à hauteur de plus
de 300 milliards de dollars à l'économie
du continent dans soit 15 milliards de
commerce en ligne également plus de 300
milliards de dollars de gains de
productivité de nombreux secteurs
tout simplement énorme grâce au
numérique
l'afrique pourra s'affranchir du
processus de développement traditionnel
réduit l'écart et le déphasage avec les
économies dominantes grâce aux tic
nous avons fait accès à ce face marché
qui nous faisait tant défaut de pouvoir
essayer de formation de qualité
observez ce qui se passe ailleurs pour
nous conformer aux standards fallait
dépasser les jeunes qui aujourd'hui
réussissent sont ceux qui ont juste
saisi de l'outil numérique et l'utiliser
au service de l'ambition est donc décidé
d'agir avec mon ami de mon âge qui
partage la passion pour la robotique
nous sommes jetés à l'eau nous voulions
concevoir un robot et cela tout seul
nous étions fous n'est ce pas et comme
tous les fous que je connais nous ne
sommes pas conscients nous savions que
nous pouvions toujours formé des
plateformes open en cause aussi où tu
solide et les loisirs et le matériel est
usé de nombreuses capacités pour
concevoir leur peau nous sommes donc
passés à la phase de collecte du
matériel et je dois avouer que le
prouver en pâtit pour obtenir une aide
matérielle était un échec mais mon ami
et moi de tenir à notre projet et ne
savent bien que jeune ou pas c'était
l'occasion plus que jamais d'agir
nous allons continuer à frapper à des
potes jusqu'à ce qu'une organes à la
place de répondre à s'intégrer cru en
nous et à nos portes réalité la ville
ancienne est de rencontrer le président
de la république à qui nous avons
présenté notre projet projet auquel la
baie à connaître toute son attention et
qu'il a promis de soutenir aujourd'hui
nous en sommes à la phase de réalisation
et il s'agit plutôt de robots downing
robot
flopée d'invention devrait s'ensuivre
mais pourquoi le président de la
république premier personnage de l'état
a semblé se disposait à nous écouter
malgré les nombreux cias que le copain
ce statut pensez vous qu'il aurait
accordé la même ouverture d'esprit et le
même enthousiasme qui l'a poussé à en
doter d'un manteau et à nous offrir un
voyage instructif
si on était plus âgé et si votre réponse
est oui pensez vous que les
sollicitations aura retenu l'attention
de l'organisation
si nous avions été plus âgés difficile à
dire mais une chose est sûre notre jeune
a énormément joué en notre faveur
une autre leçon que nous pouvons en
tirer c'est que les politiques sont plus
que jamais disposé à soutenir
technologique
ils ont en fait ils ont enfin compris
l'importance de l'économie numérique
frau des deux premières leçons qu'il a
tirées de mon expérience et d aller plus
loin beaucoup plus loin dans ma quête
d'une vie au petit vraiment épanouie car
qu'il vous souvienne ma première
motivation en me lançant dans le projet
d'invention au delà du concours
au delà de la passion pour les sciences
technologiques et de réunir assez
d'argent vous mettre une veste et
prestigieuse après le bac
ma solution était donc pas d'attendre
que mes parents face au préscolaire pour
mes rêves ma solution d'aller trouver un
travail en parallèle des études tout en
gardant en tête que je ne devais pas
impacter négativement scolaire mais où
trouver un travail
quand on a 15 ans et quand on vit dans
un environnement où les personnes plus
âgées mieux diplômés et plus compétente
peine à trouver un emploi après un bond
de recherche j'ai voulu me former un
marketing digital et un groupe à qui ce
qui m'a permis de décrocher plusieurs
certifications dont celle de maîtrise
des fondamentaux du marketing numérique
signé par google
puis j'ai je me suis lancé dans
l'approché d'un emploi c'est à croire
que c'est un réel problème dans le pays
parce qu'aucune des boîtes que contactés
ne voulait avoir fait un mineur fils il
profita kipré données l'être mais à
paris c'est pas des nations pays
aujourd'hui je supplie jeunesse
développer dans des entreprises
internationales une à dubaï et l'autre
en tunisie je suis heureux de vous
annoncer que je la respecte ma première
entreprise rennais le marketing sera
dans quelques mois une alliance
internationale de communication digitale
faut des deux premières leçons tirées de
mon expérience je n'ai pas volé mon
arrêté là je me suis formé à divers
moyens de garder l'arraché internet
j'ai créé un réseau de plus de 1000
personnes avec qui ils partagent tout ce
que je découvre à travers des formations
que je co anime le cotonou blogging
votre chope par exemple le pluriel que
j'ai fait j'ai youtube et bien d'autres
choses avec reebok 33 - leclanché
internet et les mains de lancer ma
chaîne youtube de mon blog à travers
lesquelles se conformer d'un milieu de
juin n'est pas l'afrique
on met tous les moyens de gagner de
l'argent travail à internet parce que
oui j'en suis persuadé l énergie
accélère en scène à l'autre
révolutionnaire qui pourrait aboutir sa
progression il faut juste de la
motivation et d'excès l'informateur
certaines personnes pensent qu'être plus
âgée et de plus mature dans leur est
plus d'atouts pour atteindre leurs
ambitions vous serez illusoire car elle
se réveille quatre années plus tard par
an avec toutes les charges qui en
découlent
croulant sous les dettes et sur un an
afin qu'il est trop tard et que les
meilleures années de la vie font
désormais passer si on peut retenir une
chose de mon histoire c'est que s'il
existe vraiment très passer à l'action
c'est maintenant de plus vous pouvez
enfin croire que la jeunesse africaine
peu cassé les côtes après connectés
économiquement et socialement
flamboyante américaine
excuse pour ne pas agir c'est un
problème que nous voyons autour de nous
est une opportunité un appel à innover
agir maintenant s'est agi pour vous pour
l'afrique afrique a besoin de vous a
besoin de nous la maison que nous soyons
pas nui et à plus de taper dessus merci
[Musique]